and you're doing splendidly speed
this year marks the 70th anniversary of
i love lucy and we also got to see
nicole kidman transform into the beloved
comedy icon you know being the ricardo's
gave us all a look inside lucy and desi
arnes's relationship and all the behind
the scenes drama
nicole you said that filming the grape
scene was was your favorite what was so
fun about filming that moment i think
the grape scene was very freeing and it
is
so so funny lucy
i'm home
nicole and javier bardem transformed
into lucy and desi in the film that's in
theaters and on amazon prime video now
they were one of hollywood's first power
couples that's something these two know
quite a bit about seeing kind of how
they had to balance sharing the
spotlight do you sympathize in some of
the moments that we see in in this film
yeah and i just love that they um were a
team i mean desi was so protective of
lucille primarily it's a love story it's
a tragic love story but it's a love
[Music]
story year one of my favorite scenes you
play in the bongos singing babalu i play
drums it was the singing part that it
took me a little bit of
an effort
you think we're saying ricky's stupid i
think you're saying the audience is why
do you think they made the perfect lucy
and desi because they transformed
completely
into lucy and desi for the love of god
old man this isn't hard nina arianda
takes on the role of lucy's bestie
vivian vance and jk simmons plays
william frawley aka fred mertz every day
at work was this sort of remarkable
time travel kind of experience the
kingsman movies have made over 825
million dollars combined and now a third
installment a prequel hits theaters
today get ready for the king's man
you're looking mighty dashing tonight
rape over here is the only one sporting
the suit though in the tie these guys
his two i mean you get the suit but you
were i've got the time my son you know
he's not bothering at all
he's just got a cute flat flowery shirt
on you're going to need a suit free
finds his teaching his on-screen son
harris dickinson all about being part of
the elite intelligence group known as
the kingsman in this origin film that
set during world war one jim and han
suit co-stars along with rhys iphones as
rasputin time to dance how much of that
was your real hair versus movie magic it
was a wig the great thing with rose
beauty is you know if you were to put
that wig
and that beard
on my mother and asked people who it was
they would say disputed
we've got to talk about the action
were you prepared for the physicality
that it would take i've done a number of
you know action-driven films before but
this one was presented itself with a
great great amount of challenge
we had the trainer who was
ex-military x special forces but i think
quite same as diamond i didn't quite
expect
to be doing
as much as we did
the kingsman is in theaters today
also hitting theaters today sing too
[Music]
i can't do this so reese you said that
this movie is the one that people come
up to you and mention the most right oh
for sure even over legally blonde yes
this movie like 400 billion million
people have seen this movie for me it
kind of unlocked this whole new fan base
tori kelly returns as shy mina reese
witherspoon is rosita and scarlett
johansson is back as rock and ash and in
this sequel she gets a duet with bono
you're both moms i'm sure you sing
around the house so is the reaction from
the kids like hey
mom or is it like ooh mom
when i was growing up i watched a lot of
rogers and hammerstein musicals and so i
sing a lot of these songs that are like
from the 40s
[Music]
but my daughter also now sings them but
like she she doesn't the lyrics are all
kind of weird and it's just it's just
absolutely hilarious i do this dumb
thing where i'm on the treadmill and i
sing like parts of songs because i have
my earphones really loud so i'm like hey
this is this
everybody makes fun of me
dream big dreams matthew mcconaughey
leads the pack as buster just like he
did in magic mike so we're coming up on
a new year right it marks
10 years since the original magic mike
channing just came out and said we're
doing it again anyway dallas could make
a repeat let me tell you dallas is still
alive and kicking and making money
somewhere i'd be honored to go back and
get dallas shoes i think we all still
have our thongs yeah absolutely
i'm here for all of it and by the way
the first thing film was a box office
smash it took home over
634 million dollars worldwide and
speaking of smashes well fans are still
clearly caught up in the web of
spiderman no way home
[Applause]
these people are going nuts for you
it's crazy
yeah fans went crazy for tom at the
spider-man premiere but boy was he
mesmerized when his leading lady arrived
his spidey senses kicked in just as our
interview was getting started so how are
you feeling about that and tackling that
they're losing things i think zendaya
just sounds like they're just showed up
tom leaned over to look and for 15 sweet
seconds the 25 year old stood in his
tracks putting everything on hold to
watch his girlfriend make her way to the
red carpet oh she's gone in she's gone
in she's gone
minutes later they posed together
zendaya wore a custom valentino
spiderweb dress and tom a prada suit i
honestly feel a little bit numb like
this has been the most incredible
experience this whole journey from the
day i got cast this means the world to
me can we just like stay up here all day
it is so crazy down there spider-man no
way home is in theaters now but tom
better hold on to that spidey suit we
are starting on what the next story
could be uh and we certainly want that
to be with tom holland if they'll have
me back i'll be there tom's co-star
benedict cumberbatch was also gushing
about him i'm really proud of him i know
it sounds patronizing but you know he's
younger than me like i said before to
get to see him from the moment i
remember bounding across the concrete at
long crosses awful studio we have to
shoot a lot of marvel stuff in england
hello i'm tom i've just been cast a new
spider-man i was like wow
wow congratulations and jamie foxx is
back as electro can i take you back to
the very first spider-man premiere
look at that
look at that
look at this
look at this right here
i think it's amazing
can i just say it feels so good to be
able to go back and watch movies in the
theater again yes and on christmas day
you can add american underdog the kurt
warner story to your must see list it
star zachary levi who transforms into
the legendary hall of fame quarterback
warner steps into it
the movie came together very quickly you
know it was a crash course and learning
how to be kurt and be a quarterback who
do you beef up for more kurt warner
i would say if the first shazam was
definitely the most i mean i put on like
20 pounds or something for that and i
think i maintained still about 15 of
that when i was playing curt five six
days a week working out and eating
somewhere like 4 000 calories a day of
and not fun calories by the way if it
was like haagen-dazs i'd be like let's
do it
you